non je pense que des photos de moi tu me
parles pas d'âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non j'ai fait terrain j'ai fait rendez
vous en terre inconnue et c'est oui ils
m'ont emmené les [ __ ] au mécène en
lozère dans les cévennes dans les
cévennes
mais sakho sait où je suis né ouais dans
le gard j'ai fait rendez vous en terre
inconnue à 15 minutes de chez moi
on savait ce qu'il m'a fait on s'est
appelé où on s'est appelé au téléphone
ya paillat ya trois semaines je lui ai
dit à quel point il était devenu beau
gosse il avait fait la coupe paul pogba
il a en costume s'inscrit ans et demi il
est bien que vous savez ce qu'on m'a dit
il ma vie cette phrase qui m'a tuer il
m'a dit façon toi madic beau gosse ça
tirait pas le fait que vous êtes venu du
raï khaled et ça fait après mon
oreillette frites avais tu as des miels
poids vous en aurez est ce qu'on a vu
malik bentalha entraîné qu'il ya des
maps et pour le rendre plus performant
n'ont en revanche été mis de très bien
qu'il ya des maps et oui enfin très bien
je sais pas médiane alors tu on sait que
tu un des plus grands joueurs de tous
les temps tu vient d'égaler le record de
yannick stopyra la moitié ne parle pas
du genre à laisser la parole au
président d'acer progès bourdais pour
gagner l'ex-champion à l'extrême on
attend avant l'extrait d'accord ce matin
je ne regarde jamais ses news
je te jure par hasard j'allume la télé
je tombe sur ses news il ya chambre
mardi qui cartonne et jean marc
morandini je regarde y'a frédéric lopez
qui parle de l'émission de ce soir et il
lui fait un quiz il lui dit vous
préférez ce présentateur lui ça arrive à
toi vous référez yann barthès vous
préférez cyril hanouna way et il dit bah
je préfère yann barthès dans ma tête je
me dis arrête toi là
c'est le matin je suis en sipec des miel
pops regards de soutien avec toi lie à
l'émission ce soir
et là jean marc morandini est mourant
digne et google a l'air tout ça pourquoi
on préférait yann barthès dans ma tête
je me dis répond parce que parce que ne
va pas plus loin et il dit parce que ça
vole plus haut ouais je me suis dit
rajoute un truc des oiseaux il a mis les
oiseaux nés un poteau en direct du temps
où il est allé la tête
j'appelle franck way jeudi franck sûr
que c'est vrai et il franck je parie que
ce soir cyril il parle pas de terrain
connu est ce que parce que près de lopez
il a dit qu'il préférait yann barthès
franc qui me dit mais jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie cyril ils sont fous il
a d'autres choses à faire
j'ai le message que tu m'as envoyé au
japon
j'appelle franck à 13h15 13h39 message
de cyril hanouna tejero je ne fais
aucune promo ce soir pour le crédit aux
thèses je te dis la vérité
ouais c'est que c'est un deuxième cage
pour toi parce que fred lopez il avec
nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
pantalon très vaste état des plus
horribles a créé par dieu est avec nous
ce soir est ce quartier est ce que ça ma
montre l on va alors évidemment syrie
c'était une blague
c'est un coup monté et vous l'avez
compris je rigole pas c'est un coup mais
la tête du vito corleone avoir abattu
prend des notes
j'aime pas trop la complicité que vous
avez tous les deux à quoi être jaloux
d'emblée sans rigoler et bat redescendre
vous sais que je pratique depuis les
séries le film se déroule en thaïlande à
pattaya et on va tous faire ensemble un
déjà fait jamais fait à l'étranger et il
sert et que vous mangez des choses
bizarres la lui alors lui l'uimm en ce
printemps mais vous il ya un problème il
ya plus déjà tu connais pas ma vie donc
je ne juge pas j'ai un problème depuis
longtemps
c'est alors que sam franchement de
parler de ça la td les samoa
fred je voulais te dire mais taxi ça
sort demain ou pas je suis dans le
truman show
[Musique]